should you upgrade to the new Apple
watch series 99 or the ultra 2 from the
older series 8 Ultra or even older Apple
watch models well today I'm going to
answer that question in this video by
telling you everything that has changed
as well as my own personal advice on who
should be upgrading to which model
depending on what you have right now and
to be honest I'm actually quite
surprised by Apple this year because
they gave us more upgrades than we
expected from the rumor mill and definit
a bigger upgrade compared to what we got
last year so let's start off with what's
new for the Apple Watch series 9 before
we jump into the new Apple watch Ultra 2
the biggest and most notable change is
the fact that the series 9 now comes
with a display that gets twice as bright
as before hitting 2,000 nits of peak
brightness compared to the previous
1,000 nits that's actually the same
display brightness as the original Apple
watch Ultra that I have right now which
is crazy bright and bright enough to
clearly see the display outside in the
daylight which was a huge Advantage
compared to the previous series 8 and
not only that but the display can now
get crazy dark down to only one knit of
brightness when in dark rooms or at
night which the ultra could not do and
it would honestly still be way too
bright and distracting when being in a
theater or somewhere outside at night
which is why Apple made theater mode
which basically keeps the display off
off until you need it but now with only
one knit of brightness you won't need to
use that mode anymore and the added
benefit is that it'll actually help save
battery life which is probably why they
have the same all day 18 hours of
battery life rating while having double
the peak brightness when needed Outdoors
of course the series 9 now comes in the
new pink finish which by itself might
get some people to upgrade because Apple
hasn't really had that before so I can
see it being very popular a big surprise
upgrade that Apple didn't mention is
that the storage has been upgraded from
32 to 64 GB basically the same as you
get in an iPad allowing you to store
more podcasts music or whatever else the
series 9 also comes with the new S9 chip
which has 60% more silicon transistors
and is 30% faster than before it comes
with a four core neural engine that is
up to twice as fast enabling something
very awesome awesome Siri is finally
processed on device for requests that
don't need an internet connection which
makes it a lot faster and snappier and
now Siri can access your health and
fitness data allowing you to log your
health info with Siri and on top of that
dictation is now 25% more accurate than
before which is great for responding to
messages with your voice the series 9
now comes with updated bands that are
more eco-friendly including the new fine
woven magnetic link and modern Buckle
bands that used to be leather which
honestly it really sucks because in my
opinion genuine leather is the all-time
best material you can get for Apple
watch bands but thankfully our sponsor
band work in Germany makes some of the
highest quality genuine leather bands
using wh we leather from horse hides
including this one made from rare shell
cavon and they just released their brand
new special edition handcrafted Carrera
band made from the actual interior
leather from the rare 1977 Porsche 911
Carrera 3.0 limited to only
649 bands so it's going to be super rare
and made with a unique design and you
can check out and order these bands from
band work today using the links in the
description and pinned comment below now
getting back to the new series 9
Hardware updates it also comes with the
second gen U2 Ultra wideband chip which
has a couple of really cool and unique
advantages including the new Precision
finding feature for iPhone 15 models
which makes it super easy to find your
iPhone by guiding you to it right on
your Apple watch it also has homepod
integration so you can transfer the
music from your Apple watch to your
homepod when getting close to it which
is really cool now moving further Apple
has added their brand new double tap
gesture to do a bunch of actions like
taking photos with the camera remote for
your iPhone by simply tapping your
fingers together twice it can also open
the smart stack of apps and scroll
through widgets within the stack which
is really cool but the crazy thing is
that this feature was already available
on previous watch models through the
accessibility settings but it wasn't as
reliable as the new version that just
came out out and the new version does
have more functionality like opening up
the smart stack and now let's move on to
everything new with the Apple watch
Ultra 2 unfortunately we didn't get a
new smaller size or a titanium black
finish but the ultra 2 did get a bunch
of upgrades including basically
everything that came to the series 9
like the 64 gigs of storage the new S9
sh chip and the extra features that came
alongside it as well as the new new two
ultra wideband chip and those advantages
but the biggest upgrade on the ultra 2
is that the display got a huge jump up
to 3,000 nits which is absolutely
Bonkers and I can't wait to try it out
but other than that not much else has
changed it all other than an upgrade to
72 hours of low power mode battery life
which is great and the new modular Ultra
watch face which looks absolutely
amazing but it seems like it'll also be
available on the original Ultra with the
latest software update and now with all
of those new features and changes out of
the way let's get into who should
upgrade to the series 9 well honestly if
you already have the series 7 or 8 there
really won't be that much different with
the series 9 since the design is
identical on the outside with only
internal and display brightness changes
so if you have one of those I would say
you should not upgrade now if you have
the series 5 or Series 6 it's a bit on
the fence because the general feature
set is very similar but with a
performance boost and some new sensor
upgrades and the design is a bit more
rounded with a larger display with
thinner bezels and that looks absolutely
great so only upgrade if you want some
of those new features that we got with
the series 8 and the 9 and for anyone
with a series 4 Apple watch or older yes
you should absolutely upgrade because
your battery is probably getting very
old by now and there are a ton of new
features to look forward to now moving
on to the Apple watch Ultra 2 if you
have any of the older regular series
models like the series 8 and older I
would honestly recommend upgrading
because the ultra is just so incredible
in terms of the design the feature set
the protected flat display glass and
battery life that just lasts days
it's an instant upgrade from any of the
regular watch models especially now that
it has the ultra bright 3000 nit display
and the big chip upgrade now if you have
the original Apple watch Ultra I would
say that you absolutely should not
upgrade because the 2000 nit display has
been just fine for me as well as the
performance so you probably won't notice
any differences at all other than some
of the ultra wideband and S9 chip
enabled software features
but that likely still won't make a big
difference all in all I think these new
watch models got a bigger upgrade than I
personally expected but you should also
keep in mind that apple is planning a
huge Apple watch x watch redesign in the
future maybe within the next year or two
so if you're kind of on the edge of
upgrading then I would definitely say
that you should wait until then so
hopefully you enjoy this video and if
you did go ahead and click that Circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one and definitely check out our
iPhone 15 buyers guide right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next
[Music]
video